today's topic
got this video from uh jubilee
i'm so nervous is everyone ready maybe
also gonna do a live swipe mm-hmm
yeah it's what we already do in our
heads yeah yeah well yeah of course yeah
yeah we just don't literally go yeah uh
excuse me yes unless you're a dubai
prince and then you can do that in real
life kiss you
my camel will have you
sodomize her for one night
or just
poor
[Applause]
20 versus one is a great title for a
game game game yeah of course yeah king
game you know what editor use game game
yeah gang
[Music]
yo shout out to all the white people
with no upper lips we appreciate y'all
okay
[Music]
i was eliminated on a left swipe
immediately hey just because you masked
my head because you couldn't use your
luther van drost voice god damn don't be
mad
i was i was eliminated on the first
strike
right away you like it not unusual to be
loved by anybody
no that's not the one that's tom jones
[Music]
uh
bye
awkward moment build the humps up and
dash it away hey you know this is a
shout out to that edition yo this is
actually where she went
[Music]
i know her ain't that the iq girl who's
hating on the mill i have no respect for
the military i think it was her it's
possible yeah she just dyed her hair she
looked a little she had a little sheet
yeah she thought i wanted to go
recognize her uh excuse me she went
rogue on this excuse me she went rogue
on us okay i never forget somebody i
dislike or someone that you like hey
elizabeth
[Laughter]
go ahead happy moment
yeah you can't call me a symphony i
can't say [ __ ] yeah yeah you can't call
me anymore i can't say it exactly i
can't say [ __ ]
[Music]
okay holy [ __ ] listen i don't know much
about this girl but i can tell you her
tastes are like biden's presidency all
over the place all over the place all
over the place this has been like this
pandemic everywhere i wasn't able to
i can't pin her and you know what
maybe she ain't got a type
bad [ __ ] is the only thing that you
like okay like half and half cool
hello everybody now it's all the people
who would actually go on a date with her
and i'm gonna i'm going to say seven
people are going to leave
how many think you leave ten
go
[Music]
hi friends
so for other people who say oh how do
you always pre-watch this no because i
don't and i'd be wrong sometime
[Music]
do you have his number whose number
kevin hearts
[Laughter]
well bring it back bring it back bring
it back bring it back listen if you show
his own go ahead let's go
[Laughter]
i'm sorry
on a but with a girl and her feet are
swinging like like she just got done
watching paddington bear
okay listen
i'm not about to pull out the marmalade
okay we're not going to please
guys if you guys are enjoying today's
video be sure to like and comment like
it like it and if you like the merch get
them earned and if you want 50 of people
watch the videos and don't subscribe
stop it you're already here let's have a
good laugh and let's subscribe click
okay ring the bell
hello
i'm gabby hi i'm liv live yeah like live
your life i love that i'm gabby
this is not a date this is a play date
it's two kids i like i like i like i
like i like
i like cheese
why are you here today why am i here i'm
i'm single
okay great that's good that's a good
start it's been a while since i dated
um because there was a pandemic makes
sense so i'm looking to get back out
there i'm just ready to you know
get back in there
i actually like this girl she's very
comfortable with herself which i think
is cool even if she's quirky and odd um
no she's she's genuine yeah she's
genuine yeah yeah i gotta give her a
shout out yeah yeah she wanted to swing
your feet swing your feet on your feet i
like people like this
[ __ ] if they like something they have
no reservations they'd be like
i like what i like you know and they
stare at your eyes and [ __ ] i appreciate
people are comfortable with themselves
that's what gang signing you know what
i'm saying yes
yes you're chilling
what's your sense dangling feet
i'm a professional dancer that's amazing
yeah that's why i'm always moving i
can't help it you know what's funny is i
know i know guys like this yes who after
faking a few dance classes they'd be
walking around with their headphones
you know who are my favorite dancers the
[ __ ] who ain't got no headphones on
but still good
you know what those damn [ __ ] is
literally lit because you were like
what's going on that [ __ ] brain bruh
yeah
she left out the house three o'clock in
the morning and got on the bus to go get
a sleepover yeah
15 times yo
you're gonna be dizzy as hell you're
gonna [ __ ] about it pass out
yeah he's still spinning yo i'm still
recording
i'm a kindergarten teacher you know what
i actually knew that because i've seen
you on tick-tock
oh my god uh what's your favorite movie
um bring it on probably stop i love it
yes
bring it on i see that
bring it on you remember that movie of
course the the dancing in that
horrid yeah
[Music]
yeah ah yeah we watched that [ __ ]
it's just bad it was bad when it first
got out yeah but i mean why we watched
that i'm like oh couldn't watch it
couldn't watch it a lot of those dance
movies didn't age well there's only a
few that did you guys served aged well
that was great yeah you got surface good
game and they said and they started off
strong fat man scoop timberland
whatever i say y'all gotta do whatever
that's like y'all
he's in the top three producers for
hip-hop the whole time i could say yeah
yeah he did whole album you know what
i'm gonna put in my top five because my
top five kind of type i got dilla
premier timberland pharrell
and dre
who are you taking out of those five
i'm good i'm good i'm i i got a pretty
shot right i'm good he's not a bad top
five i'm good yeah i'm good with that
okay i'm very comfortable with it all
right i just want to make sure let us
know in the comments is that a good top
five i think it's a pretty good one
there was a there was a time when it was
dre
cow and then timbaland go get andre and
then pharrell and then and then
timberland
was just there was a point where the
neptunes man listen
yeah the neptune
f2s are producing everything
no i'm too small i'd be afraid for sure
for sure totally i understand that
the way he zoomed on him they jubilee
jubilee okay i'm talking to the person
that edited that yeah you've been
watching our videos you dirty yeah and i
pretty much zoom yeah
editor needs to show be showing some
love because they're showing their
personality just about what they
highlighted the exactly if he was trying
to form a connection with her like you
jump in a mosh pit she's like nah i'm
too small yeah yeah
i see that and the closer we got from
her for the closer we got from him the
farther he got from her
oh yeah poetry
no no we saw hey the jubilee editor we
saw that poetry we start what the [ __ ]
you did there that's good
i feel like from here to here i was
pretty put together and then my legs
were where all my anxiety went because
they were just going like this the whole
time see what they did there
it looked like something you would have
done
hey i don't know what the [ __ ] hey hey
i'm still getting used to like talking
to people again they're probably like
the lulls in the conversation but
otherwise it was nice i don't really
remember much i just remembered the
scene why
uh and that was that he's not talking
about the background
the whole girl is pale he's failed she's
pale and it's okay pale is a sign of
nobility and uh sickness so good for you
do you have anyone in mind
everyone was so nice
but there is one person that i think i
want to talk to again
what happens now she's just gonna come
back
the pink hair we know it's a she
yeah you think pink hair pink hair
yeah if you bond on you got served you
must be meant to be together because
that's a shitty ass movie it's like
girls you guys are bring it on bring it
on hello again hello again
[Applause]
[Music]
hey that's a good call hey that's a good
call
that's a good call who's this you that
was you you you but you said i was like
that makes sense
yes
bring it on
come on now bring it up bring it up
bring it straight around
come on cheese i thought you could come
back and we could talk more i love that
yeah i'm really glad you picked me
because
i want to get to know you too thank you
i would ask for your phone number yeah
my phone's over there they haven't said
a word a real word they just went
by at the same time but we understood
and that is perfect this is wonderful
because you have to understand that when
it comes to two human beings connecting
with one another vast majority of
communication is non-verbal so for you
guys to not be saying anything is
perfectly acceptable and you can still
connect the same way two people can be
mute and still have a very deep bond
between each other just by gestures and
looking at each other it's why most of
us know the people we want to talk to
when we walk into a room just by looking
around like i said
don't feel judged this is a safe space
okay i didn't say [ __ ] but you know i
was judging you right why would you
judge me because i'm being accepting and
empathetic
you should try it sometimes you you
should try something you yeah me you
yeah
wasn't i comfortable playing a gay
character in the last video
this is the guy that calls me
i've never said that oh my god no no no
no no no no no no no no you have new on
numerous occasions what numerous you
never use that word on you oh
my
god that word on you
think about it get the [ __ ] out of here
i'm not ashamed to admit like jokingly
between people i know that will use
certain words the same way
you you know you got certain words that
what words
[Music]
wow that cannot go out on on youtube
that has to be like just patreon yeah
anyways let's get back to the video
yeah that was a tangent and a half i'm
so basic i have a clear phone case isn't
that like a buy thing yeah cuff jeans
clear phone case i'm a stereotype all
around
category
that's fine how can people know
so i guess you're by then too yeah
and i can't remember did you say you
were vaccinated i am i got my moderna
nice
visor
you guys are bonding over fat
you vaccinated yeah [ __ ] we're yeah
we're part of the 90
[Laughter]
what kind of you got i got the john and
johnson
i got the modern two shots same arm yes
girl how you doing like it was it was a
weird energy that's out that's how she
chose yeah that person is black he's not
fat
i'm not even mad at that
but anyways
um so my name is gabby and i'm a
kindergarten teacher yes
yes you are yeah with that voice yeah
absolutely a hundred percent you are
yes you know what's crazy is that um
kindergarten teachers are like one of
the jobs where there's the most amount
of discrimination
you can't look like you and do that job
no
you can't have our genitals and do that
job no period you ever try to be a man
working on a daycare bro
you can't you know what yay what yeah so
shout out to her congratulations what do
you do for a living i'm a kindergarten
teacher
uh call the police